I just received Ivermectin and got 18 milligrams for the dosage.
He said we could go higher next time. Does this seem to be a good starting point?
No it doesn't because really your starting point for Ivermectin for cancer
should be if you take your weight in pounds and you convert it to your weight in kilograms.
So let's say you weighed 100 kilograms. I don't know how to do that. Just go on Google and just do
conversion of pounds to kilograms. It'll come up with a little table, put it in your weight,
and then it'll convert it to kilograms. So let's say you weigh 100 kilograms to keep the simple.
The starting dosage for Ivermectin for cancer is one half milligram per kilogram weight.
So if you weigh 100 pounds, your starting dosage really needs to be 50 kilograms.
No you probably don't weigh 100 kilograms. But let's say you weigh 70 kilograms.
Then your starting dosage is 70, half of 70, which is 35 milligrams.
So the starting dosage, and this is right on the member's side.
Okay so this data is you have to remember it. It's right on the member's side, the home page.
Right on the home page gives you the dosages for fenmentozole in Ivermectin.
Starting dose for Ivermectin is change your weight in pounds to kilograms divided by two.
So if I weigh 70 kilograms, starting dose should be 35 milligrams of Ivermectin per day.
And then you move up to, if you need, if your cancer's still growing at that over a period of several
months, then you move up to one milligram per kilogram. And there's people that are going up,
going all the way up to two milligrams per kilogram in very serious cases where their cancer's
just continuing to grow like crazy. So now 18 milligrams, let's say you weigh 70 kilograms.
Then 35 would be your doses, you just take two of those. So you could stay with those pills,
you just might have to dose it accordingly.